Just like any profession, the movie industry
is filled with a wide variety of personalities
that sometimes clash with one another — especially
when some of those personalities belong to
notoriously difficult performers.
Or, otherwise decent actors who get carried
away during the grueling process of making
big budget movies and television, earning
them a "does not play well with others" reputation.
Actors like ...
William Shatner
Over the years, several of William Shatner's
former castmates have commented on the Star
Trek star's allegedly difficult attitude.
He's reportedly upset plenty of co-stars and
even caused some feuds along the way.
Shatner and fellow Trek vet Leonard Nimoy
clashed over scripts and fan mail, and Shatner
is said to be excessively sensitive to stories
that favored Nimoy.
Later in life, the pair patched up their differences,
but that belated reconciliation may be a rare
exception for Shatner.
Reportedly, Shatner and Nichelle Nichols—with
whom he shared TV's first interracial kiss—didn't
get along well at all, and she nearly left
the show until Dr. Martin Luther King convinced
Nichols of the importance of her role.
Shatner later made waves when he refused to
appear on stage with James Doohan at a convention
event in 2004—Doohan's farewell appearance
following his Alzheimer's diagnosis.
There's also the long-running feud between
George Takei and Shatner, who've been at odds—often
publicly—for several decades.
"There's such a sickness there.
It's so patently obvious that there's a psychosis
there."
"Well, I think his stability is quite questionable."
"Really?"
"Hahaha."
Shannen Doherty
Although she's managed to put her public feuds
with castmates behind her since her 2015 cancer
diagnosis, Shannen Doherty reportedly was
notoriously hard to get along with on the
sets of both Beverly Hills 90210 and Charmed.
During her 90210 years, Doherty clashed with
her co-stars, including Tori Spelling, who
recounted an incident when Doherty and Jennie
Garth nearly got into a fistfight.
Spelling has admitted that she ultimately
asked her father, 90210 producer Aaron Spelling,
to fire Doherty.
Years after the show ended, Jason Priestley
wrote candidly about Doherty's attitude in
his memoir, and Doherty responded by saying
he had "brain damage" from a car accident.
On the set of Charmed, Doherty ran into problems
again, this time with co-star Alyssa Milano,
who described the situation as "very much
sort of like high school."
Doherty agreed ...
"There was too much drama on the set and not
enough passion for the work."
Whatever caused the issues, they proved to
be too much for Doherty, or producer Aaron
Spelling, to handle, and she left the series
after the third season.
Wesley Snipes
Despite being a household name, Wesley Snipes
has developed a bad reputation in Hollywood
for his on-set antics, most notoriously during
the production of 2004's Blade: Trinity.
According to co-star Patton Oswalt, Snipes
insisted on being called "Blade," and would
rarely leave his trailer ...
"You'd walk by his trailer and this wall of,
of pot stench would just, like, woah, and
kind of push you to the side."
Oswalt also recounted a much more serious
incident in which Snipes tried to strangle
the director, David Goyer, after which Goyer
proposed th at Snipes quit, and his stand-in
finish the film.
This allegedly freaked Snipes out so much
he stopped talking to Goyer altogether ...
"After a while he, he resorted to just, give,
he would communicate with, with, uh, Post-Its.
He would give to the director, and each one
he would sign, 'Blade.'"
After filming for Blade: Trinity ended, Snipes
sued Goyer and New Line Cinema, claiming they
withheld part of his salary and didn't allow
him to be part of the creative process.
He was also allegedly upset because some of
his screen time had been reduced in favor
of Jessica Biel and Ryan Reynolds.
The suit was later settled out of court.
Lindsay Lohan
After racking up a string of early hits as
a Disney starlet, Lindsay Lohan set about
compiling a record of partying hard and leaving
frustrated directors and co-stars in her wake.
On the set of 2007's Georgia Rule, Lohan caused
so many problems with her tardiness and no-shows—reportedly
costing the production a half a million dollars
a day—that producer James Robinson sent
her an ultimatum, saying, quote, "I'm not
going to put up with it."
In 2012, a source from the set of Glee complained
that the actress had been "a total nightmare,"
again showing up several hours late to shoot.
It seems that tardiness is a bad habit of
Lohan's.
A year later, Anger Management co-star Charlie
Sheen told Jay Leno that Lohan had been late
to the set by several hours, and had later
"borrowed" a couple of bracelets from the
production, which the show later deducted
from her paycheck …
The same year, New York Times Magazine published
"Here Is What Happens When You Cast Lindsay
Lohan in Your Movie," a piece chronicling
some of Lohan's almost unbelievable misadventures
on the set of Paul Schrader's The Canyons.
Among her offenses?
Not showing up to set.
Big surprise.
Edward Norton
Though he's apparently become more easygoing
in recent years, it's been a hard battle to
repair the damage Ed Norton caused to his
reputation in the past.
That reputation?
A supposedly impossible perfectionist who
siphons creative control for himself.
While Norton is infamous for insisting that
producers give him say over the final cut
of the 1998 drama American History X, he surged
back into the headlines while promoting 2008's
The Incredible Hulk.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe is generally
action-packed, explosive, and witty.
But when Edward Norton signed on to play Bruce
Banner, he wanted a longer, more nuanced film
with a deeper dive into Banner's backstory.
Universal put its foot down, and the "creative
differences" spiraled out of control.
Norton barely even promoted the film, and
took off for a humanitarian trip to Africa
after the premiere, arguably harming the flick's
box office bottom line.
So in other words, you wouldn't like Norton
when he's angry …
roar
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!